hey this is preshtalwalker in this video
i will teach you how to calculate the
square root of a perfect square in your
head
so when would the skill have ever been
useful
here's the entrance examination for mit
in the year 1876
question three is to extract the square
root of 64 over 121
and of 11.56
the square root of the fraction is
straightforward it will be equal to 8
over 11.
but how would you calculate the square
root of 11.56
remember in 1876 students did not have
pocket calculators that would give an
answer instantly
instead they would have learned various
algorithms to solve this type of problem
in this video i will teach you one such
method
to get started you need to memorize the
squares of the numbers from 0 to 9.
then focus on the last digit of each of
the squares
notice that some of these squares end in
the same last digit
1 squared and 9 squared both ended one
two squared and eight squared both end
in four
three squared and seven squared both end
in nine and four squared and six squared
both end in six
the square of zero ends in zero that's
different from all the other squares
listed here and the square of 5 ends in
a 5 and that's different from all the
other squares listed here
so i will illustrate the method with an
example
let's calculate the square root of
sixteen hundred
first look at the last digit of sixteen
hundred
this is zero
so you now want the square whose last
digit ends in zero
there's only one option which is zero
squared is equal to zero
so we put a zero over here
then we cross out the hundreds and units
digits
we're left with the number sixteen
we now want to find the square that's
closest to 16
without exceeding 16.
in this case 4 squared is equal to 16
exactly
so we will write the digit 4 here
thus the answer is equal to 40.
now this was a simple example you
probably could have calculated it
without this method
but this method will show its value in
more difficult examples
so let's go ahead with another example
let's calculate the square root of 4225
the last digit is 5 and that corresponds
to the last digit of 5 squared which is
equal to 25 so we write the digit 5 here
we then cross out the last two digits
we now want the square that's closest to
42 without going over
so that will be six squared which is
equal to thirty-six
so we write a six over here
thus the square root of forty-two
twenty-five is equal to sixty-five
now let's go to a little more
complicated example
let's calculate the square root of eight
hundred and forty-one
the last digit is one
and that could either correspond to one
squared which ends in a one or it could
correspond to 9 squared which ends in a
1 as well
so we have 2 options of 1 and 9.
we'll sort this out in a little bit
we'll continue by crossing out the last
two digits
now we want the square that's closest to
8 without going over
so this will be 2 squared which is equal
to 4. so we write a 2 here
so now we need to go to 2 options we
either have 841 is equal to 21 squared
or 29 squared
to distinguish between the two we'll use
a genius method
we will calculate the square of 25 which
is in between 21 and 29
so there's a trick to calculating the
square of a number that ends in 5
you take the part of the number that's
not 5 in this case 2
and you multiply it by 1 more than
itself
so we take 2 multiplied by three which
is equal to six
then you append a twenty-five
so twenty-five squared is equal to six
twenty-five
notice six twenty-five is smaller than
eight hundred forty-one so 25 squared is
too little
so it must actually be the case
that 841 is equal to 29 squared
thus we take the larger option of 9.
so the square root of 841 is equal to
29.
this may sound a little complicated but
it'll get easier as we work through more
examples
let's now calculate the square root of
39.69
we go to the last digit of nine and we
know that it's either three or seven
we then cross out the last two digits
and we look for the square that's
closest to 39 without going over
this will be 6 squared which is equal to
36
so we now need to differentiate between
63 and 67
we will calculate the square of 65 which
is right in the middle
so we take 6 and multiply it by one more
than itself to get 42.
now notice
if we have 4225
that'll be larger than 3969 so 65
squared is too large
so must instead be equal to 63 squared
so thus we know the square root of 3969
is equal to 63.
wow
let's now calculate the square root of
1156
from the last digit we know the options
are either four or six
we then cross out the last two digits
we look for the square closest to 11
without going over which will be three
we now need to differentiate between 34
and 36
so we take 3 multiplied by 1 more than
itself which is 12.
now 12 is larger than 11 so we need to
pick the smaller option of 4.
thus the square root of 1156 is equal to
34.
we can adapt this solution to calculate
the square root of 11.56
this will be equal to 3.4
now let's calculate the square root of
sixteen thousand three hundred
eighty-four
from the last digit we know the two
options are either two or eight
then we cross out the last two digits
we want the square that's closest to 163
without exceeding 163
this will be 12 squared which is 144.
we now take 12 multiplied by 1 more than
itself which is 156
then we see that 156 is smaller than 163
so we take the larger option of eight
thus the square root of sixteen thousand
three hundred eighty four is equal to
one hundred and twenty eight
wow i will mention that you can also
adapt this method to calculate the cube
root of a number
you of course first have to memorize the
cubes of the numbers from 0 to 9.
then the procedure is very similar in
fact it's even easier because each of
the last digits is different
so we look for the cube whose last digit
is equal to 4 the only option is 4 cubed
which is equal to 64.
so we put down a 4 here
we then cross out the last 3 digits
we look for the cube that's closest to
39 without going over
this will be equal to 3 cubed which is
27.
so we put a 3 here thus the cube root of
39
304 is equal to 34.
amazing
now in the present day we often take
arithmetic for granted because we have
pocket calculators and powerful
computers
but historically the new calculating
methods were revolutionary
let's go back to the early 1200s in
europe when roman numerals were the
standard practice
good luck trying to add multiply or
calculate the square root of roman
numerals in your head
calculations were instead done on an
abacus and translated back and forth to
roman numerals
but with indian numerals calculations
could be done directly from the numerals
the adoption of the indian numerals
didn't happen right away there was
actually a competition between the two
systems and it took hundreds of years
until indian numerals became the
standard
i will close with a quote from the great
french mathematician laplace
it is india that gave us the ingenious
method of expressing all numbers by the
means of 10 symbols each symbol
receiving a value of position as well as
an absolute value
a profound and important idea which
appears so simple to us now that we
ignore its true merit
but its very simplicity the great ease
which it has lent to all computations
puts our arithmetic in the first rank of
useful inventions
and we shall appreciate the grandeur of
this achievement when we remember that
it escaped the genius of archimedes and
apollonius two of the greatest minds
produced by antiquity
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time